okay if someone's a christian
you would be putting your body under
because biblically you want you want to
you are monogamous you're faithful
somebody of the islamic faith would say
what percent of men do you think really
are that religious that they don't want
to have sex with a lot of girls
no no percentage of them i get it but
you know that so so i think if we had a
jar in the middle that said but this
exception and pathetic
most men they would like the mother of
their child to only be one right and
then they
if they create offspring the majority of
men will say that i would like to only
have one mother that's cat
no one no yeah no
but jason derulo's little like baby mama
can go on social media and complain and
cry about how jason derulo cheated on
her when you're dating jason derulo what
do you think was gonna happen so you're
saying that whoever you get with you
should expect that's what i'm saying
i'm saying i'm saying if you want a guy
on a certain level he's gonna cheat on
you okay like i'm just saying like if i
said don't don't yeah don't be dating
these celebrities these nba players and
confuse but and i'm saying like we
wouldn't like them
if they couldn't cheat we'd like got
like pre-selection is very important for
women
so it's really important to us that we
see other women like the guy that we
want i feel like guys i've heard guys
say if a girl if a guy does not approach
my woman i like i need that to see
that's not no no
if a guy if a guy if a guy sees an
instagram that has a thousand or less
followers it's private
no he's not but i'm saying like if
instagram is the extreme right and i
take you take it to the extreme to like
look at the argument so if a dude if a
girl has a million guys thirsting over
her on on instagram even if it's not
sexual content is that a green flag or a
red flag
red yeah red
what about eddie wouldn't you feel a bit
of validation it's not trust me that's
my plan oh i might feel a bit of
validation but i don't want it no i'm
not saying
there's a proverb that says marrying a
pretty girl is like planting crops next
to a busy street because everyone's
gonna pick up the crowd but like you
would rather have a woman that you knew
was beautiful that no one moved to
that's why
it's impossible
but
the difference the difference is women
are attracted to that like when a guy's
in a room and you can tell other girls
want him that's attractive to us
that's attractive like when drake's in
the club the girls aren't thinking oh no
too many girls want him like
nah they're they're moving to drake
but vice versa guys aren't attracted
like they're not saying oh that's so hot
that that guy approached my girl i'm so
turned on right now yeah it's not hot no
it's not hot but i've heard some guys
say like like someone's gonna back you
up i'm saying like some guys will
like the validation right if you walk in
the room i don't know
if you walked in a room right now it was
a party and you walked in and your girl
and the whole room went quiet
and you're saying yo to everybody
everyone's looking at her the validation
is guest bro the validation and wanting
are two separate things
you would feel a bit of validation for
it yeah but you don't necessarily want
it because you know it's impossible it's
like it's just just one of those
i'm a man so i'm territorial so all that
sense with that situation is potential
trouble yeah i don't want that yeah i
know for a fact that someone's going to
test my character by trying to move to
my girlfriend that shit's going to get
there
in front of you
that's a violation but then you should
know your woman and know she's going to
shut it down said are you telling me
that you would rather go for an average
thing that you're not gonna get too
territorial over or you'd rather go
before so it's not about being
territorials about what is what makes
most sense in the situation i probably
wouldn't be in certain situations with
my girl i would expect her to know
better 100 or just stay at home
it doesn't make sense so
who
wants to improve more
men are women
men
i think men will improve more because
they have to because
their value comes from what they can
create for themselves
so they have to
men definitely i was going to say i feel
like women want to improve on their
looks men just want more money and
things to offer but we both want to
improve
on different things but if women want to
improve more on looks then why are women
more overweight than men
are they new facts yeah are they yes are
they
yes i don't know
70 percent of women in america are
avoiding maybe
no it's not it's not that much better
here it's not i don't i don't have the
stats off the top of my head but i've
looked it up before the western europe
yeah yeah because because you guys would
always everyone i'm from america
everyone talks [ __ ] to me and like say
something and i'm like and i looked up
the stats here i'm like it's not much
better
it i think i think uh as an overweight
person i can probably speak on this
um
it helps a man to get more money
regardless of what he looks like
but for a woman she can improve
herself and it wouldn't really make a
difference
to how she's treated in most situations
because not all women are eights or tens
so i think uh
my person what i'm saying with it like a
five with a banging body like she still
gets a ton of attention but what what
you're calling the five mm-hmm a certain
man might not call a five he might call
you eight or two mm-hmm so i think no
there's general standards there is i do
feel like there's more motivation
needed to improve yourself as a woman
well for myself i've struggled with my
weight so i know that the motivation i
put into my business for example i
haven't put it into myself in the same
way
but i know that because my business is
thriving the same energy i put into that
i can use it and apply it into my weight
but i feel like there's some there's a
lot of women out there who maybe they
don't have the mental capacity because
they haven't achieved anything or they
haven't successfully done something for
themselves so that there's that lack of
motivation to even look at themselves
yeah i think it's down to the fact that
men um women are born of value whilst
men have to create their value so even
as a woman you can just walk out there
on the street someone's going to cater
to you in some way shape or form as a
man before you even get awarded a seat
at the sexual marketplace table you need
to become something you need to be worth
something
if you're lucky enough to be born good
looking young then that's your entrance
but for most men that's not the case for
most women you can be but ugly as long
as you've got a ton ton someone's gonna
try and stick it somewhere so i think
that's the fundamental difference you
have to acknowledge that you're born of
valuables we have to create do you think
if you couldn't get a relationship that
you would lose weight quicker if you got
no attention from men in the world
i probably wouldn't be overweight i
think i've always said my problem is i
still get attention yeah
and now the attention is even different
because
you know the body shape i have looks
like the body shape that women are
paying for
so for me it's annoying because even
though i shouldn't really compare myself
to people i'm annoyed i'm like i just
wish i i hated myself but enough to
change wouldn't you say in a way that
work that's men bailing out women for
bad decisions
in a way
because yeah yeah yeah probably talking
about something girl's gonna say i've
had this conversation with men where
they're like i don't care like they've
been on dates they don't actually ask
the girl what she does because they
don't care they don't care yeah so i was
going to say so is it it's like a shoe
collection so so could you say that like
not that they don't want us to improve
but let's say she works at mcdonald's
you not don't actually require
sometimes you don't require
much edification well yeah but they want
us to look hot yeah so they might and
they might want us to be less
argumentative they just improve in
certain aspects but maybe not in
feminine friendly submissive and it
depends on the quality of guy you're
going for the problem is that the
market's always good because there's
such a small fraction of when you're
actually worth something in society so
the men who aren't worth something are
the ones that are going to be like you
know what if she gives it up
their hyenas is ready to pounce so i
think that's part of the problem
it's funny i remember having that